[Music]
[Music]
in 2021 the legend of zelda turned 35
years old and just recently so did i but
if there's anything the flow of time
hasn't been cruel on it's the zelda
theory community over the past years
nintendo's willingness to communicate
and share information with the fans has
been better than ever before and in the
grander scheme of things this is still a
fairly recent development it's easy to
forget that for the majority of zelda
history nintendo wasn't exactly diligent
in explaining the overarching story and
lore of the series now some games were
clearly meant to be connected the
earliest example being zelda 2 the
adventure of link a direct sequel to the
original but as more and more entries
were added it became apparent that
nintendo's priorities lie in creating
interesting gameplay experiences above
anything else and nowhere is this more
discernible than with the infamous zelda
timeline which was and to an extent
still is a subject of debate amongst the
fanbase even though i grew up with the
games i wasn't aware of this discussion
until i was already in my 20s when the
angry video game nerd made a video about
it prior to that i simply enjoyed
playing the games and didn't really
think about how they all fit together or
what the deeper meaning behind a
specific location or character was
little did i know other fans were hard
at work behind the scenes it's hard to
say when the first fan made timelines
were conceptualized many websites and
forums from the old days no longer exist
so there's a good chance that a
significant part of zelda theory history
is lost forever i did however manage to
find a few gems like this timeline from
north castle made in a time when the
wind waker was still the hottest title
or this one from kasuto.net which only
includes six games with majora's mask
being the newest addition furthermore
zelda universe.net which is still alive
and well today has four impose spanning
all the way back to 2006 when twilight
princess was brand new it was a lot of
fun scrubbing through these old web
pages and forums reading theories and
seeing the discussions that took place
at the time it's clear that there was a
lot more uncertainty and division back
then which is not surprising at this
stage nintendo had never released their
own official take on the matter in old
interviews miyamoto sometimes alluded to
the order of specific games that were
out at the time but not only would these
statements contradict each other on some
occasions they would often change as the
series moved on when the creators
themselves don't seem to be sure of
themselves it's easy to come to the
conclusion that perhaps there is no
rhyme or reason to all of it and any
attempts to dissect these stories or
trying to fit them all together is a
waste of effort and this is kind of how
things were back in the day when it came
to an official zelda chronology nintendo
remained mostly silent for no less than
25 years and so the fans were left to
their own devices
but everything changed when hyrule
historia attacked in 2011 as part of
zelda's 25th anniversary nintendo teamed
up with japanese publisher shigakucon to
produce an official hardcover book
containing a wealth of information and
artwork never before seen it was
initially only available in japanese and
wouldn't be localized for western
audiences until two years later for the
english localization nintendo approached
dark horse comics an american publisher
from oregon who specializes in both the
production and localization of comic
books graphic novels manga and other
types of media aside from the obvious
text translations the page design itself
remained virtually unchanged however the
dimensions and cover art would be
altered by darkhorse ditching the old
design in favor of a slightly bigger
green heart cover featuring the symbol
of the gate of time from skyward sword a
few reasons for the change was that
first of all by the time the english
edition came out the 25th anniversary
ship had sailed so it wouldn't make
sense to keep the anniversary logo on
the cover and second the dimensions of
the japanese version while common in
japan wasn't a standard for art books
like these in the us and so the whole
thing was upscaled the color green was
initially chosen by darkhorse to
represent link's iconic attire and the
gate of time symbol is both a nod a
skyward sword which is a big focus of
historia as well as a symbolic gesture
that the book offers a glimpse into the
series past which i think is very clever
despite the emphasis on skyward sword
historia also has an entire section
devoted to the chronology of the series
as a whole including the very first
official zelda timeline after 25 years
nintendo finally broke the silence and
gave the fans their own extensive take
on the zelda universe the book ended up
being a massive success especially in
north america taking top spots on
various bestseller lists among famous
titles like harry potter and even
knocking 50 shades of grey down a peg
which i don't know makes me feel a
strong sense of justice for some reason
it would have been reasonable to expect
nintendo to go back to the silent
treatment after this but little did we
know that this would be the start of a
new age for zelda fans the book's
success clearly showed that there's a
high enough demand to know more about
these stories so for the 30th
anniversary nintendo doubled down or
should i say triple down with even more
zelda literature to celebrate the
anniversary nintendo released arts and
artifacts also known as hierographics in
japan and the legend of zelda
encyclopedia would follow soon after
which when combined with hyrule historia
became known as the goddess trilogy or
goddess collection since a lot of time
had passed since historia's release
close to six years in fact encyclopedia
introduced a new chronology with a few
revisions a link between worlds and
triforce heroes which didn't exist back
in 2011 were added and link's awakening
in the oracle game swap positions as of
today this is still the most up-to-date
official timeline pertaining to every
mainline zelda game but breath of the
wild and seeing as aj onuma is reluctant
to reveal the timeline placement of that
game it'll likely stay that way for
quite a while speaking of which as the
final entry to commemorate zelda's 30th
anniversary we got creating a champion
also known as masterworks a book solely
devoted to the lore and development
history of breath the wild and features
its own timeline of events with every
other game having been condensed into a
single era the era of myth with the
addition of these new books the colors
red blue and green came to represent the
three golden goddesses hence why it's
known as the goddess trilogy and
creating a champion's white cover was
chosen to symbolize hylia the fourth
prominent goddess in the series lore
well at least for the western editions
that is the same consistency cannot be
found in the japanese editions as their
version of hyrule astoria has a brown
cover so they kinda did their own thing
especially in the color department
however the dimensions and overall look
and few of the japanese books that
followed historia were brought in line
with the north american versions there's
quite a lot of collector's editions and
limited editions as well all of which
look completely different but the ones
you see here are the designs most people
are familiar with as a zelda theorist i
adore these books they are such a gold
mine of information to draw inspiration
and ideas from those who are familiar
with my channel know that i don't shy
away from taking bits and pieces to
construct theories or at the very least
use them as supporting evidence to give
some extra weight to them these
publications have had a significant
impact on the zelda community most
notably of course the acknowledgment of
an official chronology by nintendo which
before 2011 only seemed to exist in the
minds of the fanbase however there's one
issue which has surrounded these books
ever since their inception and that is
that not everyone seems to accept them
as canon or at the very least only
partially the encyclopedia in particular
has often been criticized in this regard
the most common arguments made against
their canonicity usually refer to either
mistakes inconsistencies and retcons in
some of the lore or question the
involvement of those who actually made
the games during the creation of the
books and it's easy to see why i mean
nintendo is like area 51 very secretive
and they don't share much about what
goes on behind closed doors pair that
with a list of credits almost none of
which are members of the zelda team as
well as a paragraph that seems to
suggest that the writers interpreted the
lore on their own and you've got a solid
recipe for all kinds of assumptions and
doubts when it comes to the actual
content inside the books i've always
existed somewhere in the middle
sometimes i'll use the books to add to
my theories but i've also pointed out
mistakes or challenged some of the lore
inside them but in regards to nintendo's
involvement in the writing process i've
never really had a strong opinion on the
matter because frankly i have no idea i
wasn't involved in these projects and
most likely neither were you i think
this is a topic worth exploring most
notably the part about nintendo's
involvement in the writing process after
all context matters and it can have a
pretty significant impact on how we view
zelda canon in the future especially if
more books like these end up being in
the pipeline so for this video i decided
to dig into it i looked at the kind of
work that went into the books the people
behind their creation both on the
english and the japanese side and i'll
also touch upon some of the counter
evidence to see how they hold up to add
some extra credence to my research i
decided to contact patrick thorpe senior
editor at dark horse comics who together
with his team was at the forefront of
the english localization you'll find his
name prominently featured in all four
books and he has a lot of experience in
publishing art books of a similar nature
like the halo encyclopedia and the art
of mass effect for example he was kind
enough to share some of his knowledge
and insights with me about the kind of
work that goes into these projects on
the side of the publisher whenever i
felt unsure about something or needed
something cleared up i was able to ask
questions so suffice to say this video
wouldn't have been possible without him
we also talked extensively on video so
on some occasions i will give the stage
to patrick himself so we can hear what
he has to say so let's get into it
now before we get into detail about the
books themselves it's important to
mention that nintendo's licensing and
official merchandising has changed a lot
over the past decades there was a time
when the company's subsidiaries like
nintendo of america operated much more
independently and had a lot of freedom
to make their own marketing decisions in
general the company as a whole didn't
seem all too concerned with things like
licensing canonicity and quality control
it was a bit of a free-for-all which led
to the creation of all sorts of products
that are now considered as a stain on
the legacy of some of nintendo's biggest
ips it goes without saying that this
early material is not canon to the
franchise they were made under very
different circumstances in a time when
the company simply didn't care as much
but those days are long gone nowadays
every licensed product is under strict
supervision of nintendo hq in japan to
ensure that the quality is worthy of
association whether it's a spin-off an
official soundtrack or a localization
effort it's all made under the watchful
eye of the japanese board of directors
this is why we haven't seen a mario or
zelda cartoon since and why the upcoming
mario movie is only the second attempt
in close to 30 years i guess those scars
really run deep when it comes to printed
material it's a different story however
even some prints from way back when are
still considered canon to the series
today like the official manuals which in
case you're interested are still
available in digital format on
nintendo's websites the older games were
somewhat limited in how much story they
could tell so often times the manuals
would fill in the gaps and give us more
insight into the story the world as well
as how things were supposed to look like
outside the game's primitive graphics
another case of older prints that are
still considered canon are the official
nintendo players guides like the 1992 a
link to the past guide for example they
are canon because well it's official
it's published by nintendo has their
seal of approval has a lot of cool
looking official artwork and aside from
being a strategy guide also features
quite a bit of lore exposition and
backstory which isn't found in the game
itself then there's publications that
aren't canon to the zelda timeline but
are categorized as an official nintendo
licensed product like the comic books
most notably the ones by akira himawaka
as amazing as these comics are there is
a good reason why most of them are not
considered true to the chronology there
are often retellings of already
established stories from the games an
alternate version of events so to speak
like the story of ocarina of time retold
they border more on fan fiction than
anything else still i highly recommend
giving them a read as they are very
entertaining if you've ever wanted to
see mido get his ass kicked by link then
this is for you there's a lot more
printed material like unofficial guides
and magazines trading cards and books
which don't have any connection to
nintendo but these are not official and
thus have no bearing on the zelda cannon
whatsoever so let's move on to the main
event the goddess trilogy plus creating
a champion which i guess could be
considered the goddess tetralogy now
it's important to note that all four of
these books were made long after the
shift in nintendo's policy regarding
marketing and merchandising in other
words nintendo of japan had the final
say and are also the ones who instigated
these projects hence why the japanese
editions always came out first so is
there any substance to the claim that
nintendo's contribution to the writing
process was minimal or that the writers
and editors hired for the job were given
free range to insert their own head
canon into the series lore i'm not over
exaggerating when i say that i've seen
estimates of 50
75 90 even 100 of the content inside
having been made up by third parties
however no one seems to explain where
they got these numbers from and without
credible evidence or proper credentials
to back it up these estimates seem to be
completely arbitrary so i asked patrick
about some of the stuff that happens
during the creation process and how the
content exchange generally works between
the licensor in this case nintendo and
the publisher so let's see what he has
to say my name is patrick thorpe i'm a
senior editor at dark horse comics i've
been there for about 15 years and dark
horse does everything from art books to
comic books to television shows and
movies what happens is that the license
order goes into their archives and they
find any usable items anything that they
would love to get out in the world so
that includes some like production
materials sketch materials backgrounds
you know stuff that you wouldn't
normally see then we'll go back to the
licensor and ask them what they have to
say about those particular things like
whether that is link or princess zelda
the master chief you know kratos from
god of war whatever that might be right
what do you have to say about this
particular character or this particular
vehicle or or what have you and
generally what happens is we either
interview them and ask them about it or
we uh we just say we need 500 words and
you know they'll shoot us back some text
it'll be like you know 400 to 500 words
that we put into the book so it comes
directly from them so
when we are doing books of this nature
you know it's my job to present what
nintendo wants in the way that is the
most true to nintendo's intent right so
i i don't come up with any of the
content for for these books right like
our job is to present the material in
the most unbiased way that we possibly
can in the most accurate way that we
possibly can and that means that we are
constantly checking in with nintendo
they're giving us the material to put in
these books we are constantly uh staying
back what we do you know as soon as we
have designed a page or whatever else we
send it back to nintendo to check our
accuracy every step of the way like is a
collaboration between us and nintendo
you know at this point darkhorse has
done hundreds of these kinds of books it
takes
dozens of people sometimes even more
than that to to create books like this
right books like an encyclopedia
generally take somewhere between like a
year and a half to two years to put
together because a lot of the time the
licensor has to organize all of the
assets make sure that they're high
resolution enough to go to print we
generally have you know a point person
on the side of the license or who is
sort of project manager on that side and
i'm working with them to
figure all of those things out one of
the things that we really like to do is
when we're hiring outside contractors to
do writing for books of this nature we
try to hire a freelancer from the
company that we're working with right
our main concern is is creating as
authentic an experience for the fans as
we possibly can and that means that we
want the stories and the insights
straight from the horse's mouth we want
to make sure that when we are presenting
information that is the information that
the people creating games want present
you know that's that's sort of the way
that we approach things is we want their
story you know it's it's not our job to
to sort of like create their story what
we want is to give them the ability to
tell their own story
now i will be fair and say that
patrick's knowledge is limited to the
scope of the english versions neither he
nor i claim to know the exact nature of
the exchange between nintendo and the
japanese publishing companies and unless
we can get aonuma on the phone we likely
never will i did however manage to find
a decent amount of information on some
of the people and organizations on the
japanese side obviously i won't be able
to cover every single individual because
first of all that would take ages and
secondly not everyone listed here has a
strong internet presence they might as
well live on a different planet from
where i'm standing but we can at least
put a face to the general collective so
we have a better understanding of who
these people are and what their
relationship to nintendo as well as the
zelda franchise is so the big players to
keep in mind here are shigakukan ambid
limited and takuma shoten shigako khan
is the publisher of hyrule historia
while ombud is credited as the official
publisher of all the other books that
followed i was initially a bit confused
since the wikipedia page for
encyclopedia as well as the zelda wiki
page for creating a champion credit to
kuma shoten who are perhaps most well
known in the west for nintendo dream
magazine a sort of japanese equivalent
to nintendo power but still active today
however the books themselves clearly say
that ombit limited is the official
publisher wikipedia
using wikipedia is your source of
information
it took me ages to find anything about
ambit which wasn't helped by the fact
that i don't read a single word of
japanese but after a long search i
finally managed to track down one
employee whose resume led me to a
japanese wikipedia page about the
company as well as an official twitter
account so here's the deal ombud limited
was established by a former
editor-in-chief at takuma shoten so it's
basically an offshoot company while they
are two separate independent companies
they do work closely together on various
projects like nintendo dream magazine
for example and ombit's twitter account
goes on to explain that the sales of
their publications are mainly outsourced
to takuma shoten likewise since 2011
ambit has also started working on
projects related to shigakukan and one
of their employees was already involved
in the creation of hyrule historia back
in 2011 as well then we have akinori sao
one of the writers for encyclopedia and
creating a champion he too was an
editor-in-chief for nintendo dream
magazine years ago but was already
working freelance by the time he worked
on the zelda books over the past years
he's written various articles for
nintendo's official website including
the famous column iwada asks in which
the former president of nintendo would
sit down and talk to employees sao has
conducted interviews with pretty much
every big name out there including anuma
and miyamoto and according to his own
biography moved to kyoto to be closer to
nintendo hq it's clear that the
companies and freelancers who worked on
these books all have connections to each
other to some degree more importantly
they all have a good long-standing
relationship with nintendo some spanning
back decades for example takuma shotan
also co-published the official link to
the past guide from the 90s i talked
about earlier which like i stated is
still considered canon and even though
shugaku khan was no longer involved in
the zelda art books after historia they
do still produce other nintendo licensed
prints like the official breath of the
wild strategy guide we have to remember
that nintendo is a video game company
not a book or magazine publisher that's
not their core business so when a
project like an art book or an official
strategy guide comes along they do what
most companies do and outsource certain
tasks to people and businesses who
specialize in these fields in this case
print but that doesn't mean that these
people are given the freedom to do
whatever they want i think patrick
already demonstrated quite clearly that
the notion that nintendo was barely
involved is factually incorrect not only
did they provide all the assets
including raw text but every word
written every image placement every page
design everything was scrutinized
checked for accuracy and ultimately
approved by the company and even if a
specific text wasn't written by a zelda
staff member directly there's still a
good chance that they were at least
interviewed about it i suspect that most
of the claims made about the book simply
stem from a limited understanding about
how books like these come to be which is
understandable if you don't work in this
field we tend to see the term writer or
editor and draw all kinds of conclusions
about their contributions but the truth
is that there's a lot of nuance to these
job descriptions the fact that a third
party is credited as a writer or editor
in these books doesn't really say much
about the nature of the content itself
nor does it imply that they inserted
their own ideas and opinions into it or
if they did by how much in fact most
professional writers are hired to put
other people's ideas into words or help
improve readability correct spelling and
grammar or refine the narrative
structure to make it more engaging for
the consumer usually it's not their job
to write the lore that is the author's
job in this case nintendo and as the
author they have full control over what
makes it into the book and what doesn't
professional writers are good with words
you know spelling grammar story
structure all the rules of how to put
them together and how to keep readers
engaged on the other side of this coin
is the author an author is someone who
organizes an idea into a book format
with the intention of putting it through
a publishing process writing isn't even
the author's
job they have their business that
they're running writing a book is
something they do to support their
position within that business many
authors again especially non-fiction
don't know spelling grammar story
structure or how to put all of those
things together beyond the basics they
know the ideas that they want to teach
and the impact that they want to make
but they don't really know how to put
that impact into words that are going to
sit on a bookshelf for the world to read
now does that mean that every single
word written in the books came directly
from the minds of the zelda team
i wouldn't go that far i'm definitely
open to the idea that there could have
been some back and forth between the two
parties i'm not here to prove that the
writers on the japanese side gave
absolutely zero input because unless i
can get into contact with one of them i
can't but i can at least give you a more
honest and accurate view on the matter
and from what i've learned over the past
weeks i think it's hardly warranted to
call 50 or more of the book's content
the product of a third party's
imagination i'd say a more realistic
estimate would be that about five
percent of the content could have been
shaped or inspired by external input and
suggestions and that's being generous
here's the thing though if the
contributions of an outsider who's not a
core member of the zelda team somehow
diminishes canonicity then we might as
well start questioning the games as well
because even here contractors are not
unusual for example the script
supervisor for breath of the wild the
one responsible for the continuity of
the story is a freelance writer not an
employee working for the company the
important thing to take away from all
this is that at the end of the day as
the author nintendo is the one who
ultimately decides what makes it into
the book and when you read the
interviews with miyamoto aonuma
fujiburashi and other staff members it
becomes clear time and time again that
the books were made with their full
cooperation support and consent and
honestly this should be the expectation
to suggest that the zelda team simply
gave up tons of precious information to
some third party information which prior
to the books had never been released to
the public and then set back as someone
else potentially destroys their
established lore requires that we ignore
how nintendo as a company operates we
all know how protective they are about
their intellectual property some might
even say a little overprotective those
who are dissatisfied with some of the
content inside the book seem to suggest
that the ones who made them probably
didn't understand the lore very well and
that it would have been better if
nintendo had involved actual fans who
have more experience with it you know
people like me or other zelda theorists
i guess but those who worked on the
books are fans of the games some of them
have been collaborating with nintendo on
official zelda projects since the late
80s and as opposed to most fans like you
and i they have direct access to the
people who made the games they can
interview them ask questions and request
assets a luxury most of us don't have so
safe to say these really were the best
people for the job in fact one of the
things that struck me the most while
talking to patrick is just how much he
knows and cares about the lore he's been
on board with the series ever since the
original and has lived and breathed
zelda lore for years while working on
these books for the localization of
creating a champion he personally fast
traveled to every single location
mentioned in the book to do fact
checking these are not just random
people who are just doing a job without
actually caring for the ip out of
curiosity i also asked about the
translation process from japanese to
english because i know it's something
people often worry about whenever
localization takes place this wasn't
intended to be part of the script but
since it exists i might as well show it
to you as some of you might find it
interesting the connection was a bit
unstable during this segment so there's
a few sections at the beginning and i
couldn't really use so to give a bit of
context patrick starts out by explaining
that the process begins with a
translation program a bit like google
translate but better what the program
does is it gives you sort of a
one-to-one translation of what this is
japanese english and then what they do
after that is they put human eyeballs on
that translation because obviously like
context matters and so we have human
translators go through and give us a
more accurate translation of that text
what we do from there is you know i take
a look at it and my team we have a
couple of japanese speakers at dark
horse as well we basically fact check
everything that's in that text for the
encyclopedia that meant going through
you know the text from all the video
games it means using all the resources
at our disposal a lot of which were
provided by nintendo right
just sort of like excel sheets that have
all the characters or the hardware that
link would use or the clothing or
whatever else and make sure that the
translation matches you know what the
actual thing is right and a lot of the
time like they'll have the japanese text
next to the english text and so we can
just like reference them one to one we
can just look up a word in japanese and
then what the english translation is
will be right next to it and so you know
in that case we can be as accurate as
possible so now let's take a quick look
at some of the evidence used against the
books it goes without saying that i
won't be able to cover everything ever
said so i'll just focus on the most
common ones i could find the first and
probably most damning piece of evidence
is the paragraph i briefly showed at the
beginning it's an excerpt found at the
bottom of page 8 of the zelda
encyclopedia and reads that quote where
necessary the writers of this book added
their own interpretations and expanded
upon the game's stories and yeah there's
an argument to be made that this does
indeed confirm that there was at least
some speculation going on however
there's also a flip side to this
argument first of all the text doesn't
say anything about how much of the
content falls under the category of
interpretation it just says where
necessary so how anyone could derive
actual numbers and percentages from this
is beyond me i also don't really see how
this affects the legitimacy of all four
books since this paragraph is only found
in encyclopedia but oh well secondly i
think i've already demonstrated that
writer is a very loose term and again
the text doesn't specifically say who
did the interpreting in many instances
nintendo themselves are credited as both
the author and writer we don't really
know who this is referring to exactly
because the entire book is one giant
collaboration between many people
including the zelda team but there's a
paragraph right above this one that may
shed some more light on what exactly is
being said here it says that quote some
elements at play behind early titles
were not spoken of at the time of
release and interpretations of these
first adventures of link in hyrule have
evolved to include the context of later
games just to be sure i also checked
with patrick and he confirms that the
statements on this page were provided by
nintendo it's basically just a reminder
that hey sometimes there simply isn't
enough information in the games
themselves to provide indisputable facts
and it goes on to say that the events
mentioned are subject to revision and
let's be honest this shouldn't come as a
surprise the zelda cannon has evolved
numerous times over the past decades
before skyward sword nobody knew where
the master sword originally came from or
how it was made all we had was one vague
statement from twilight princess about
the ancient sages being involved somehow
so had a similar book like hyrule
historia been released around this time
the book may have included a very
different backstory for the master sword
next is this statement made by onuma
during an interview with gamesradar in
2017. quote we published a book with a
timeline but we definitely got some
comments from users saying is this
really accurate i think this should be
this way it's different and history is
always kind of imaginative it's left to
the person who writes the book so that's
how we approach it as well it's not
necessarily that we come up with a game
and think oh this is where it fits into
the timeline some see this as an
admittance that the books are a product
of someone else's imagination mainly
because of this part of the statement
it's left to the person who writes the
book but if you look at what's being
said here it's obvious that he isn't
referring to the zelda books it's a
general statement about real life
history we all know the classic saying
history is written by the victors he
feels that people questioning the
accuracy of the zelda books is only
natural and it should be this way
because just like real history some of
it is imaginative in no way does it
imply that the zelda books were solely
written by other people and thus
shouldn't be taken seriously if we're
gonna use one specific quote from a
staff member as leverage i think it's
only fair that i do the same so in
contrast let's look at a few different
statements made by a zelda staff member
about one of the books like this one
from fujibayashi found in the back of
creating a champion quote there were
backstories for particular settings
during development but they were very
complex so we couldn't explain them in
the game this book allows us the
opportunity to tell those stories which
makes the development team and me very
happy or how about this one from aonuma
in the back of hyrule historia quote i
found myself wondering whether there was
anything left we would be able to
compile into a book that's how the
legend of zelda hyrule historia came to
be or this one from encyclopedia quote
this encyclopedia is the fruit of all of
our labors showcasing how we've taken on
all sorts of challenges of course the
reason that we're able to publish this
sort of book or even make breath of the
wild is because of the fans who
supported us does any of this sound like
they're not taking these books seriously
or that it's just a group of outsiders
making stuff up while the zelda team
sits back and does nothing to contribute
everywhere you look you see the same
type of sentiment we published a book it
allows us to tell those stories
fujibarashi even stated that they do
concern themselves with things like the
timeline because they know it's
important to people speaking of the
timeline i want to quickly address one
more aspect before i move on to the
final segment namely aunuma's secret
document which holds the true zelda
timeline this is real by the way he
actually said this in an interview with
the uk's official nintendo magazine that
there's a top secret document on his
computer that only himself miyamoto and
fujibayashi are allowed to see and which
allegedly holds the quote-unquote real
zelda timeline this has led some to
suggest that the timelines from hyrule
historia and encyclopedia are not the
real deal and are again the product of
some third party so basically anuma is
hiding the truth from us that tricky
bastard what they don't seem to realize
is that this interview was conducted in
2010 well over a year before hiro
historia was published as much as i love
a good conspiracy theory i have to
appeal to your sense of logic here what
do you think is the more likely scenario
that the zelda staff would publish an
official zelda lore book with an
incorrect timeline made up by some third
party while secretly hiding the real one
or that the secret document anuma is
referring to here is simply one of the
assets they were putting together in
preparation for hyrule historia which
was set to release one and a half years
later i will leave that up for you to
decide now with all that said i do have
to even out the playing field and say
that even though it may not seem that
way given all i've said i actually do
agree to some extent with those who are
critical of the books i think labeling
them as non-canon or trying to say that
they shouldn't be taken seriously is
definitely a step too far but i do share
the belief that the book should not be
taken as a gospel on zelda lore you know
what nintendo agrees with you there's a
good reason why the books include so
many phrases like it is believed or it
is said or it could be the creators of
the games have always made it abundantly
clear that they want to encourage people
to speculate challenge ideas or come up
with their own or look for new
discoveries zelda canon is flexible it
always has been it is shaped by both the
creators of the games as well as the
fans who interpret these stories years
even decades down the line aunuma
himself explains that the gameplay is
always at the forefront of development
and that the stories could be considered
afterthoughts that often fall into place
by chance even the official timeline has
a footnote that states that it is
subject to change based on new
discoveries and the player's imagination
these are all reminders that some
aspects of the lore are not set in stone
and are a continuous puzzle that evolves
over time and yes the books do indeed
contain mistakes and again this really
shouldn't come as a surprise i mean look
at the size of them with this amount of
content spanning across 18 games some of
which were made in the 80s and 90s no
amount of double triple unquadrakin
tuple checking is going to filter out
every oversight some arguments made
against the books are downright petty
pointing out the smallest mistakes in
the print as if it somehow proves the
incompetence of those who put their
hearts and souls into these projects
like this one for example where they
accidentally flipped the fire in the
spirit medallion this has been fixed in
later editions by the way including mine
so it's not even relevant anymore but
there are definitely versions out there
that feature this mistake now look i'm
one of the biggest zelda lore freaks out
there it's become my job pretty much and
even i accidentally mixed up two of the
medallions in one of my videos mistakes
happen it doesn't mean the people who
worked on the books are incompetent or
didn't care and patrick himself can
vouch for this he's well aware of every
mistake and oversight as an editor
working on books of this size you kinda
have to accept the fact that you'll
never get everything right these
projects can't go on forever they have
budgets and deadlines and let's not
forget that every mistake is also one
that nintendo themselves failed to catch
as for inconsistencies in the lore
itself again i have to ask what did you
expect we all know that zelda lore isn't
perfect and the staff will be the first
to admit this a book like hyrule astoria
encyclopedia or creating a champion will
never be able to give you all the
answers and they were never meant to
they are meant to enrich the world of
zelda to tell stories the developers
weren't able to tell in the games
themselves and sometimes these stories
will be speculative it's also worth
considering that sometimes the creators
themselves may not even remember the
original meaning behind something they
wrote years ago which may sound weird
but it's more common than you think take
for example my favorite band muse in
2001 they released a song called plug-in
baby and ever since then fans have been
trying to find out what the lyrics and
its title actually mean in interviews
lead singer matthew bellamy changed up
the story behind the song so many times
that it only became more confusing and
when finally asked by a fan in front of
a live audience his ultimate answer was
i can't remember now where is it i read
i read some book about like i don't know
what it was something to do with um
like uh my playing maybe um
i don't know i can't remember
when a piece of art or content wraps up
creators move on to new things and they
don't always retain every detail behind
the choices they made stories evolve
creators change their mind and the
bigger an ip gets the harder it becomes
to keep it all together and consistent
even the best of the best in the
industry make revisions and amendments
to their work the original story of the
hobbit was changed in later editions to
make it more compatible with the story
of lord of the rings some of the lore
from the original metroid prime was
altered for similar reasons the zelda
games are no different they too contain
inconsistencies retcons contradictions
and localization differences some games
even have two versions like ocarina of
time and majora's mask which have key
differences in some of the dialogue and
especially in their environments so
which version is canon the old one
because it was the original vision of
the creators or the new one where they
may have had the opportunity to rethink
certain lore aspects or make them more
consistent with games that came after
like how they included the happy mask
salesman's backpack in ocarina of time
3d i don't think one option is
automatically inferior to the other both
could and should be able to serve as
evidence to support your theory of
choice so why can't the same thing apply
to the books only sticking to one type
of media has always struck me as a bit
counter-intuitive because there was a
time when printed material held the same
value as the games themselves they
expanded upon all sorts of aspects the
games weren't able to communicate either
because of technical limitations time
restraints or because it would have
padded out the game too much some of the
most interesting parts of breath the
wild story take place in creating a
champion things we would have never
known about if it wasn't for the
existence of this book like the story of
akala citadel the evacuations of central
hyrule and many other interesting
stories related to specific buildings or
characters as i mentioned at the very
beginning for the majority of zelda
history we weren't even sure if nintendo
cared about zelda lore or timelines but
after decades of silence they opened up
their archives and gave us an excessive
amount of information artwork and ideas
we never had access to before i say use
that information and if something
doesn't add up by all means challenge it
create your own theory write a book send
it to nintendo i don't know and maybe
one day when a new game or book comes
out you may just see one of your
theories become a fact so next time
someone references the zelda
encyclopedia or creating a champion
don't simply hand wave it away or tell
them to stick to the games on the flip
side when someone challenges the lore
inside the books it's also worth
listening because they may be onto
something every discovery we make could
potentially shape or inspire future
books games timelines maybe even movies
limiting yourself to only one type of
media one language or one idea goes
against everything zelda lore stands for
people have dug up the most obscure
references localization differences beta
elements and so on some of it from the
games some from the books or the manuals
or even interviews all in search of
ideas and inspiration
in conclusion i feel like there's enough
indications that the zelda team was most
definitely involved to a high enough
degree to consider this a product of
their making and thus they are a canon
edition to the series but in true zelda
fashion their contents are not
indisputable and could be subject to
change and revision in the future to
some degree it already has seeing as the
timeline from hyrule historia was made
obsolete by encyclopedia you may have
noticed that i haven't really touched
upon specific lore details like the
infamous section in the zelda
encyclopedia that talks about majora's
mask being some sort of dream i would
have loved to triple the runtime of this
video and talk about it and oh believe
me it's day is coming but i didn't want
to turn this into a lore video that
wasn't my intention here if i talk about
one contradictory piece of lore i have
to talk about all of them and this
project was already getting out of hand
my goal was to show you more about how
these books came to be and some of the
people behind it if you still believe
the books are not canon even after all
i've said that's fine you do you there
is a thing called headcanon zelda is not
like star wars or lord of the rings
where most things are explained and
fleshed out in great detail the
adventures and backstories are purposely
set up as ancient legends that may or
may not be true with a lot of gaps that
require the imagination of the player
it's an endless puzzle that'll continue
to introduce new pieces to work with and
the day we solve everything is the day
that zelda theories cease to exist let's
hope that day never comes and with that
i have said all i wanted to say on the
matter thank you for watching the video
it goes without saying that a huge huge
thanks goes to patrick thorpe from dark
horse comics who's been at my side for
the past weeks answering questions and
giving amazing insight into the work
that goes into these projects another
shout out goes to rawan who sent me
these amazing miniature manuals of some
of the games since i don't own a lot of
the official manuals physically it
actually came in handy for the video so
thank you very much there's a link to
the etsy store in the description in
case you want to pick up one of these
for yourself as always a big thanks to
my supporters on patreon and my channel
members and say hello to a few newcomers
it's bats invade and raid watermelon
hugo wolf's guard thavest dill pickle
desecrated cake brandon eccle and alex
sp thank you so much for joining also a
special thanks to chap c for gifting me
some of these new memberships now go and
watch me scream like a little girl in
one of his streams go up up up up up
here's the stairs no
i don't know where the stairs is
i will see you all next time this is
dawn signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you